jacques laurent bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes appelés aussi jeudi pour nos amis
les plus jeunes qui ne le savent pas
cécile saint laurent quand vous avez
écrit la fameuse série d'aidés caroline
chérie beaucoup d'autres pseudos dont
albéric varennes vous êtes écrivain
scénariste adaptateur alors jacques
laurent vous êtes né en 1919 en outre
annoncé jacques laurans célibataire
était avocat qui était ruinée d'ailleurs
et vous dites je déteste mon enfance et
je méprise ceux qui ne déteste pas la
leur à vous ennuyer beaucoup conviti
enfants et c'est comme ça vous êtes
devenu en fait un grand lecteur non je
vois vous avez raison référent nuit qui
va pousser un réfugié la rive est passé
mon temps à lire et à partir de là j'ai
écris parce que tout écrivain est un
ancien oui tout jeunes écrivains
étrangers les torts
dans le côté obscur devant la france
antipathique
j'ai un vaillant de fraîcheur et de
plaisir c'est la lecture
alors vous avez lu beaucoup et lubin
ville qui vous a beaucoup marqué à un
livre très important d'ailleurs qui
s'appelle conséquences politiques de la
paix étaient publiés en 1919 dont
d'ailleurs les livres dont les
prédictions se sont réalisées pendant
tous l'entrée de guerre c'est un
vraiment un livre prophétique et c'était
le grand choc de vos 20 ans mais comme
vous étiez pas militante nature n'est
pas un militant non vous n'avez pas
militer à l'action française et tout ça
parce que vous n'êtes pas à peser pas
une nature de militants ou c'est le
moins qu'on puisse en dire
tellement qu'en plus c'est le moins que
l'on puisse en dire mais en même temps
ce royalisme vous a permis de d'éviter
de céder au fascisme oui aussi le fait
que maurras attaqué le attaqué le
facisme beaumont nantis coin et qu'il
avait réussi à me faire ironise ouais
mais c'est ça sert que vous pas plus que
maurras vous croyez une restauration
monarchique
mais la pensée de morale surtout les
amants de venise disons vous éloigne du
romantisme qui mène la jeunesse de
l'époque soit au fascisme et au
communisme
en fait les deux grandes idéologies
destructrices initialement elles sont
romantiques toutes les deux j'allais
résister à l'invasion du sentiment quoi
et ça va être tellement ri
oui mais pas que j'aie jamais cru qu'il
pourrait y avoir une restauration
monarchique enfermé c'est un athéisme
politique qui est très stendhalien d'une
certaine façon ça non mais oui un oui
alors vous allez lu marx évidemment à
l'époque vous l'avez trouvé séduisant
mais mais vous avez très vite compris
enfin sur le plan intellectuel
évidemment c'est très séduisant mais
vous allez très vite compris que c'était
une utopie
et puis a eu les procès de moscou et
vous dites les crimes du stalinisme
on était connu très tôt en fait oui
c'est une chose d'ailleurs que jamais pu
m'expliquer les commerces de français
savait que les gens qui vivaient à
anvers et de les prisonniers ne pouvait
pas sortir sauf rien n'a vraiment
d'explication à la police que sans
explication on pouvait lire foutrement
la grue lag que c'était un régime
infernale les c'est comme lui ce forcené
le savait et pourtant avec la meilleure
foi du monde est resté comme ils sont
restés très longtemps communiste n'a pas
eu peur il n'y a pas eu de nuremberg du
communisme non plus nous alors après on
vous retrouvez la sorbonne et puis c'est
la mobilisation c'est la guerre si vous
commencez une licence de philo c'est
vous dire vous ne finirait jamais vos
études
voilà ça vous a pas empêché d'écrire des
vues magnifiques et alors vous retrouvez
caporal dans l'armée d'armistice à
surveiller la ligne de démarcation et là
tranquillement vous commencé à écrire ce
qui sera votre premier roman mais qui
sera public en 48 les corps tranquille
alors avant de publier les corps
tranquille en 47 sous le nom de cécile
saint laurent vous publiez
caroline chérie alors vous appeler
cécile saint laurent vous dites parce
que ça rappelait le canada et cécile b
de mieux c'est bon mais oui mais voilà
quand j'ai fait comme lille c'était un
bazou commercial qui devait me permettre
de subventionner le jacques laurent
descos tranquille bien que j'étais amené
en effet quelques temps après voilà
olinga l'argent cécile salon était le
mécène de jacques laurent gros succès
car une chérie traduit en 12 langues et
puis film évidemment avec l'inoubliable
martine carol voilà vous avez beaucoup
d'argent c'est une époque de votre vie
où vous vous flambée pas mal
les voyages les palaces c'est ce que
vous appelez votre belle époque et alors
les week-ends au bout du monde et vous
avez une anecdote formidable c'est qu'à
l'époque il y avait encore des dans les
aéroports y avait des comptoirs pour les
voyageurs sans bagages oui et je partais
pour l'amérique du sud et les hôtesses
de ce comptoir
j'étais le premier voyageur sans bagage
au l'amérique du sud
oui et louis harel au 20 août hey les
chapelles oui alors là vous financez la
parisienne revue littéraire dont on
parle encore souvent dans cette émission
vous dirigez art et alors là ce qui
montre votre modernité votre ouverture
d'esprit vous confier la critique de
cinéma dans art ascii sera quelques
années plus tard la nouvelle vague c'est
à dire truffaut chabrol godard romer ils
travaillent tous pour vous inquiétez
d'inconnus et les peaux dorées et il
faut dire que j'ai été largement aidé
dans la gestion la page cinéma par mon
ami joël allegri vous avez fait des
films après avec bien sûr laurent 51
vous publiez un livre paul et jean paul
alors paul c'est paul bourget écrivain
bourgeois traditionnel un
traditionaliste même jean-paul
évidemment c'est jean paul ça vous vous
défendez le ce que vous appelez le roman
dégagé contre le roman engagé le leader
à la littérature dégagé qu'en
littérature engagée et sartre vous dites
il faut que je leur ai dit qu'ils lisent
donc si je commençais à la halle comparé
au diable ça va lui faire trop plaisir
donc vous décidez de le ridiculiser et
là vous le comparez à paul bourget vous
dites qu en fait paul bourget aussi
faisait de la littérature engage engagé
mais lui il était au service de la
bourgeoisie conservatrice et donc vous
dites à sartre finalement vous faites
exactement la même chose avec vos romans
que bourget avec les siens et en
commençant g avant j'avais un peu
l'impression de gagner le faire canular
ouais
et oui et puis j'ai lu du
du pôle baugé je n'avais pas fait ma
lecture favorite
j'ai lu du projet et je me suis aperçu
que c'était mais encore plus mais je
faisais des vraies mais que même là
leurs impressions j'avais fait un voyage
en amérique et rusal unis l'année
l'autre il disait à peu près les mêmes
choses
alors cette parenté entre ce jeu
révolutionnaire de conservateur a tardé
oublier des mots des ragas ça m'a charmé
très ironique c'est très très fort ça
c'est pour ça que j'en parle c'est d'une
grande ironie bien amusé alors on pas
citer tous vos bouquins mais enfin c'est
vrai qu'il y en a quelques-uns quand
même qui mérite qu'on en parle en 64
vous faites mauriac sous de gaulle parce
que mauriac était confit en dévotion
pour de gaulle il l'idolâtré vous dites
un mauriac idolâtrant général acariâtre
il ya eu un procès vous avez été
attaqués pour offense au chef de l'état
oui je suis passé la 17e chambre
correctionnelle et monsieur bien amusez
vous ne vouliez pas beaucoup en fait
parce que vous étiez par vous étiez
jarry vous étiez plutôt algérie
française et vous étiez c'est un peu une
forme de noeud comment dire dedans 10
mais enfin vous souteniez low as donc
effectivement vous étiez par rapport à
de gaulle dans le code dans le camp
adverse voilà alors il ya eu ce procès
donc la 17e tout l'intelligentzia est
venu témoigner pour vous mais pas que
des packs des gens de droite il tout le
monde a justement j'ai pas pris cinq ans
il ya eu revel il ya eu chez pas enfin
les jantes revel gaieté à gauche et bien
sûr et
justement je ne voulais pas que viennent
témoigner mon passé et des gens des gens
de droite des gens favorables à l'ouest
soit des gens qui quittent et marié
uniquement en faveur de la liberté
d'écriture et bien malgré tout ce qui
est incroyable c'est que vous avez été
condamné et le livre ça c'est très sain
croyable aussi a été amputé de 25 pages
oui mais la police n'a jamais exécuté
avant avant ça je savais pas alors ah
oui le livre est plein de continuer à se
vendre quelqu'un alors on 71 ans était
en 64 7 ans plus tard 71 vous publiez
les bêtises prix goncourt
un veau meilleur livre en 80 il ya eu
plein de livres entre temps dans 80 les
sous-ensembles flou et en 86 vous
rentrez à l'académie française
alors aujourd'hui ben vous à vous avez
pas de maison enfin dans l'appartement
mais pas vous n'êtes pas de richesse que
vous n'êtes pas de voiture vous avez
quand il parlait je sais pas si c'est
vrai mais quand vous allez acheter un
costume vous laisser l'ancien et vous
partez avec le nouveau c'est vrai ça
j'ai pas tout à fait vrai mais raide
jouer ouais vous croyez pas en dieu
vous êtes un anarchiste de droite on
peut dire ça si on veut que je suis pas
l monarchiste parce que le j'aime bien
même temps l'ordre c'est boulot j'aime
bien jardin à la française
j'ai pas tellement vrai jardin anglais
ouais donc je peux pas être complètement
lâché même pas anarchiste de droite je
me suis retrouvé à une question il ya
beaucoup de temps
une vingtaine d'années cette
questionnaire de proust fois qu'on dit
questionnaire de proust
quel est pour vous le compte de la
misère et vous répondiez la société de
consommation
il ya longtemps que vous consommez pas
je consomme aller mais je ne garde pas
ouais ne le conserve pas je consomme
sans conserver alors vous dites quand
vous faites le bilan de votre vie vous
dit j'ai une existence passionnante mais
j'ai jamais eu conscience du bonheur que
j'ai eus je ne rendais pas compte que
fonds se trouvaient toutes les choses
normales et or il n'est pas normal
devant un énorme succès maria bohlin et
de gagner des millions et puis tous les
films j'ai pas parlé des films oui il
adapté que j'avais écrit et ce n'était
pas normal s'était dessinée exceptionnel
j'aurais dû en être conscient le nom
n'était pas conscient pour ça que je
vivais pas s'avouer ouais et alors je
reviens à mon questionnaire de proust la
question quand vous avez posé on vous
avait demandé justement quel est votre
rêve de bonheur et vous aviez répondu à
la personne
je répondrai pas à ça c'est une question
trop bête j'étais bien déjà là bien
écouter j'étais très heureux de vous de
vous revoir merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
finale andy tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux